you're one of the greatest teachers of
machine learning AI ever from cs231n to
today what advice would you give to
beginners interested in getting into
machine learning
beginners are often focused on like what
to do and I think the focus should be
more like how much you do so I I'm kind
of like believer on a high level in this
10 000 hours kind of concept where
you just kind of have to just pick the
things where you can spend time and you
you care about and you're interested in
you literally have to put in 10 000
hours of work
um it doesn't even like matter as much
like where you put it and you'll iterate
and you'll improve and you'll waste some
time I don't know if there's a better
way you need to put in 10 000 hours but
I think it's actually really nice
because I feel like there's some sense
of determinism about being an expert at
a thing if you spend ten thousand hours
you can literally pick an arbitrary
thing and I think if you spend ten
thousand hours of deliberate effort and
work you actually will become an expert
at it and so I think it's kind of like a
nice thought
um and so uh basically I would focus
more on like are you spending ten
thousand hours that's what I'm focus on
so and then thinking about what kind of
mechanisms maximize your likelihood of
getting to ten thousand dollars exactly
which for us silly humans means probably
forming a daily habit of like every
single day actually doing the thing
whatever helps you so I do think to a
large extent is a psychological problem
for yourself uh one other thing that I
hope that I think is helpful for the
psychology of it is many times people
compare themselves to others in the area
I think this is very harmful only
compare yourself to you from some time
ago like say a year ago are you better
than you year ago this is the only way
to think
um and I think this then you can see
your progress and it's very motivating
that's so interesting that focus on the
quantity of ours because I think a lot
of people uh in the beginner stage but
actually throughout get paralyzed
uh by uh the choice like which one do I
pick this path or this path yeah like
they'll literally get paralyzed by like
which ID to use well they're worried
yeah they're worried about all these
things but the thing is some of the you
you will waste time doing something
wrong yes you will eventually figure out
it's not right you will accumulate scar
tissue and next time you'll grow
stronger because next time you'll have
the scar tissue and next time you'll
learn from it and now next time you come
into a similar situation you'll be like
all right
I messed up I've spent a lot of time
working on things that never materialize
into anything and I have all that scar
tissue and I have some intuitions about
what was useful what wasn't useful how
things turned out so all those mistakes
were uh were not dead work you know so I
just think you should just focus on
working what have you done what have you
done last week
uh that's a good question actually to
ask for for a lot of things not just
machine learning
um it's a good way to cut the
the I forgot what the term will use but
the fluff the blubber whatever the uh
the inefficiencies in life uh what do
you love about teaching you seem to find
yourself
often in the like drawn to teaching
you're very good at it but you're also
drawn to it I mean I don't think I love
teaching I love happy humans
and happy humans like when I teach yes I
I wouldn't say I hate teaching I
tolerate teaching but it's not like the
act of teaching that I like it's it's
that um you know I I have some I have
something I'm actually okay at it yes
I'm okay at teaching and people
appreciate it a lot yeah and uh so I'm
just happy to try to be helpful and uh
teaching itself is not like the most I
mean it's really no it can be really
annoying frustrating I was working on a
bunch of lectures just now I was
reminded back to my days of 231 and just
how much work it is to create some of
these materials and make them good the
amount of iteration and thought and you
go down blind alleys and just how much
you change it so creating something good
um in terms of like educational value is
really hard and uh it's not fun it's
difficult so for people should
definitely go watch your new stuff you
put out there are lectures where you're
actually building the thing like from
like you said the code is truth so
discussing uh back propagation by
building it by looking through and just
the whole thing so how difficult is that
to prepare for I think that's a really
powerful way to teach how did you have
to prepare for that or are you just live
thinking through it I will typically do
like say three takes and then I take
like the the better take uh so I do
multiple takes and I take some of the
better takes and then I just build out a
lecture that way uh sometimes I have to
delete 30 minutes of content because it
just went down in alley that I didn't
like too much there's about a bunch of
iteration and it probably takes me you
know somewhere around 10 hours to create
one hour of content to give one hour
it's interesting I mean is it difficult
to go back to the like the basics do you
draw a lot of like wisdom from going
back to the basics yeah going back to
back propagation loss functions where
they come from and one thing I like
about teaching a lot honestly is it
definitely strengthens your
understanding uh so it's not a purely
altruistic activity it's a way to learn
if you have to explain something to
someone uh you realize you have gaps in
knowledge uh and so I even surprised
myself in those lectures like also the
result will obviously look at this and
then the result doesn't look like it and
I'm like okay I thought I understood
yeah
but that's why it's really cool to
literally code you run it in a notebook
and it gives you a result and you're
like oh wow yes and like actual numbers
actual input X you know actual code yeah
it's not mathematical symbols Etc the
source of Truth is the code it's not
slides it's just like let's build it
it's beautiful you're a rare human in
that sense